Це - один із найбільших інфраструктурних проєктів Німеччини.
Три мільярди євро - приблизно стільки коштує будівництво газопроводу Eugal,
наземного продовження "Північного потоку-2" територією Німеччини.
Хоча будівництво ще не завершене,
інвестори повідомляють, що їхні витрати вже окупилися
і 80% потужностей газогону заброньовані наперед - на 17 років.
Будівництво інфраструктури наземного продовження
"Північного потоку-2" триває, наче нічого й не сталося.
Всі труби газопроводу вже укладені під землю,
а тут, за 50 кілометрів на південь від Берліна,
закінчується будівництво компресорної станції.
Федеральна земля Бранденбург, селище Раделанд.
Під півтораметровим шаром піску ховається
сухопутне продовження газопроводів "Північний потік-1" та "Північний потік-2".
Завдання компресорної станції, яку тут зводять, -
підвищувати тиск, який газ втрачає, долаючи
численні кілометри шляху, і прокачувати паливо далі по трубі.
Станція має запрацювати наприкінці цього року
одночасно з другою ниткою трубопроводу.
Керівник будівництва Фред Зудбрінк запевняє, що все буде готове вчасно.
Протягом останніх чотирьох років він працює в компанії Gascade, яка будує газопровід Eugal.
За його словами, коронавірус не зміг порушити плани будівельників.
Роботи не припинялися.
У нас є кілька підрядників, які використовували
робітників із Італії, Польщі, колишньої Югославії,
і їм потрібно було дотримуватися 14-денного карантину, що призвело до затримок робіт.
А в іншому - жодних проблем.
Іронія долі: три компресорні установки німецького виробництва
обладнані турбінами зі США, що надає пікантності ситуації
на тлі безперервних погроз з Вашингтона про нові санкції.
Намагатися говорити про політику з робітниками марно,
тож ми адресуємо питання щодо санкцій проти "Північного потоку-2"
офіційному представнику компанії Gascade.
Звичайно, ми стежимо за ситуацією і за тим, що відбувається у геополітиці.
Але оскільки зараз компанії Gascade санкції не стосуються, у нас лише роль спостерігача.
Тим часом Бундестаг нещодавно проголосував за відмову
від вугільних електростанцій до 2038 року. Для влади у регіонах Німеччини
це означає одне: потреба в газі буде зростати.
Факт у тому, що енергетична реформа буде можлива
тільки за рахунок заміни енергоносіїв,
а лише відновлюваних джерел недостатньо хоча б через те, що
вони нестабільні: вітер дме не постійно, сонце світить не завжди.
Основою енергогенерації були вугільні та атомні електростанції,
які в недалекому майбутньому мають зникнути.
Це означає, що нам потрібен новий енергоносій,
який може постачати енергію безперервно, коли інших джерел у нас в розпорядженні немає,
і це природний раз. І зрозуміло, що поступово під час енергетичної реформи з 2015 року
потреба в газі зростає, і ми знаємо, звідки він береться.
Джерело газу для нас у Східній Німеччині - це, перш за все, Росія.
У Gascade кажуть, що новий газопровід за потреби
можна використовувати для прокачування газу
з різних джерел і в різних напрямках, і що першою ниткою "Північного потоку"
вже прокачується газ, який надходить Північно-Європейським газогоном.
Є різні можливості. Зрозуміло, що на півночі є джерело,
але є й підключення по осі Захід-Схід, як у Раделанді,
так і під Берліном, тож там газ можна транспортувати
у різних напрямках для посилення мережі.
У керівника цього будівництва щодо необхідності газопроводу
й великої політики є власна думка.
Те, що ця станція будується, з моєї точки зору, звичайно, добре,
тому що я цим заробляю на хліб.
У сусідньому селищі Раделанд живе лише 183 людини.
Але гігантська інфраструктура наземних продовжень "Північного потоку"
зробила його ключовим пунктом на картах поставок
російського газу європейським споживачам.